mais d'abord c'est aujourd'hui canidalgo
dévoilait officiellement son programme
revalorisation du SMIC ISF climatique
droit de vote à 16 ans la candidate
socialiste joue sa survie Jonathan du
prieze Annie dalgo ira jusqu'au bout
sans primaire mais avec un programme 70
propositions pour répondre à l'urgence
sociale climatique et démocratique avec
ce projet présidentiel la mère de Paris
espère faire décoller une campagne qui
patine depuis des mois ce projet est un
projet riche il est neuf il est complet
et donc il est financé en priorité un
Hidalgo veut revaloriser le travail et
les salaires abroger la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ou encore augmenter
sensiblement le SMIC ma mesure
celle que je vous présente ce matin et
que je prendrai dès le début de mon
mandat c'est le SMIC qui sera relevé de
15% soit 200 euros net par mois la
candidate PS entendent aussi faire de
l'écologie le combat du siècle ainsi
elle souhaite inscrire dans la
Constitution la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique ou encore aller
le plus rapidement possible vers 100%
d'énergie renouvelable d'autres mesures
sont avancées notamment un plan
pluriannuel de rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments entièrement prise en
charge par l'État la Caisse des dépôts
est consignation avancera l'argent
nécessaire aux travaux directement
auprès des entreprises qui les
réaliseront et elle se remboursera
ensuite plus tard au moment de la vente
ou de la transmission du logement par
héritage enfin sur le plan de la
démocratie la candidate socialiste veut
renforcer les droits directs du peuple
avec cette mesure
issue des gilets jaunes repris à son
compte oui il pas un référendum qui
pourra être déclenchée par un groupe de
français sur les questions importantes
qui leur tiennent à cœur avec un
programme dans la droite ligne de
social-démocratie précis et chiffrées
anidalgo rêve encore de renverser la
table à 3 mois de la présidentielle mais
la campagne s'annonce difficile pour la
candidate PS actuellement crédité de 3 à
5% dans les sondages et on va donc
commencer ce débat évidemment en
analysant la candidature Dani dalgo sa
dynamique de campagne ou pas et celle de
la gauche en général je vous présente
mes invités Noël Mamère bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes essayiste ancien
candidat écologiste à la présidentielle
vous publiez le cas Zemmour comment en
est-on arrivé là c'est aux éditions les
petits matins Bérengère Bonte bonsoir
Bérengère journaliste auteur de Le Sioux
c'est un portrait d'Édouard Philippe
publié aux éditions de l'archipel Pascal
Perino politologue bonsoir Pascal
professeur à Sciences Po avec nous en
duplex steward show qui est consultant
en stratégie d'opinion chez Viavoice
bonsoir Stewart bienvenue Euro 2 de vous
retrouver vous aussi et Laetitia cruppa
éditorialise politique bonsoir Laetitia
bienvenue à vous on démarre donc avec
Anne Hidalgo elle ma mère est-ce que
vous avez j'imagine écouter ses
propositions sont programmes officielles
est-ce qu'elle peut encore sauver sa
campagne pour vous je ne sais pas si
elle peut sauver sa campagne ce que j'ai
constaté c'est que elle a beaucoup
emprunté à ce que disent les écologistes
depuis un certain nombre d'années par
exemple l'ISF climatique était une idée
promue par Eric Piol le maire de
Grenoble qui était candidat à les primes
à la primaire le programme 100%
rénovation thermique disons que c'est un
programme social-démocrate avec une
bonne une bonne une bonne cuillère si je
puis dire de d'écologie est-ce que ça
réussira à convaincre les Français le
problème c'est que vous l'avez dit nous
sommes à 100 jours du 2e tour je pense
que ce sera extrêmement difficile pour
un Hidalgo de décoller je crois que les
faux
dire la vérité et la vérité c'est que la
gauche est tout candidat a réunie pour
l'instant en tout cas séparé puisqu'ils
sont balkanisés d'une certaine manière
la gauche est dans l'impasse ça va être
extrêmement compliqué durant ces jours
de faire comprendre aux Français que par
exemple l'écologie est un outil de lutte
contre les inégalités et non pas comme
le disent ces adversaires un instrument
de punition que c'est un outil
d'émancipation et que pour le faire
comprendre dans un monde où l'on cherche
le clash plutôt que l'explication où on
cherche la simplification comme si le
monde était binaire c'est extrêmement
compliqué de réintroduire dans le débat
public un petit peu de complexité je
pense que jusqu'à maintenant ce à quoi
nous assistons de la part de la dans le
débat public qui est comme vous avez pu
le constater extrêmement droitisé on
assiste quand même à une manière comme
si on voulait éteindre les français
plutôt que de les éclairer notre votre
boulot notre boulot de politique c'est
de contribuer à éclairer les Français et
je pense avoir pour l'instant le courage
de la bouffer en sorte qu'il y ait de la
confusion de la confusion politique on
ne sait plus qui est de droite qui est
de gauche qui est de droite qui est
l'extrême droite au point que d'ailleurs
des candidats d'extrême droite comme
Zemmour arrivent pour apporter de
l'ordre dans la confusion ce qui est
quand même assez assez incroyable et je
pense que dans une certaine partie du
métier du journaliste que j'ai pratiqué
un certain nombre de médias ne
favorisent pas ne se force pas beaucoup
bon pour éclairer l'opinion on y
reviendra notamment sur la
responsabilité médiatique sont pas les
seuls mais il y en a une dans dans le
phénomène Zemmour qui s'est peut-être un
peu de cassé
politique je voudrais qu'on continue sur
la oui bien sûr c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit on n'est pas les seuls je voudrais
qu'on parle de toujours de la gauche et
peut-être avec avec vous Bérengère il y
a une histoire de calendrier quand même
annoncé alors c'était prévu et la
manifestation des enseignants est venue
se impacter aux phase se fracasser sur
mais ça tombe mal quoi c'est pas le
bonjour pour annoncer son programme de
officiel non et quand ça veut pas ça
veut pas et franchement la pauvre parce
que on ne peut pas dire autre chose
tous les médias évidemment sont
concentrés sur cette ce mouvement à
l'école c'est difficulté du covid à
l'école et évidemment présenter un
programme qui en plus emprunte non
seulement écologistes mais aussi à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le le la
planification écologique c'était un
terme qui a mis Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans
la campagne enfin on se demande bien ce
qui reste dire Dani dalgo qui a
tellement été inconstante depuis le
début qui qui dit au printemps qu'elle
ne sera pas candidate qui ensuite l'Est
qui dit qu'elle veut pas de primaire
puis qu'elle en veut une puis qu'elle en
veut pas tout ça dans un dans un
effectivement un calendrier qui est
quand même assez complexe et à quelques
jours maintenant d'une primaire
populaire qui va avoir lieu de toute
façon même si donc elle n'y est plus ou
elle n'y est pas avec peut-être beaucoup
de gens qui vont y participer donc
exactement ça va être une vraie une
vraie question il y a 130
populaire qui sont oui
d'accords
180 000 votants ça va quand même avoir
un peu de poids ça n'aura pas
officiellement de valeur mais si un
Mélangeon ou une Christiane
taubirables
on en revient
Pascal Perrineau est-ce qu'il pourrait
renoncer tiens à Hidalgo ah oui elle
pourrait renoncer si vous voulez pour un
candidat socialiste se retrouvait aux
alentours de 4 à 5%
d'attention de vote au bout d'un moment
on doit se poser des questions parce que
le seul à avoir atteint sous la
Cinquième République à un tel niveau
qu'il faut espérer pour un Hidalgo est
un niveau de palier à partir duquel elle
ne pourra que rebondir ces Gaston de fer
en 1969 mais à l'époque j'allais dire on
avait après Mai 68 une gauche qui était
en voie de disparition et on peut se
dire que peut-être la gauche est en voie
de disparition en tout cas le Parti
socialiste qui était tout de même
l'ossature principal de la gauche sous
la Cinquième République c'était autour
de lui que s'organiser ce qu'on a appelé
la bipolarisation et pour l'instant le
gros problème de la gauche il y en a
deux c'est d'abord que l'ensemble de la
gauche est une incroyable faiblesse vous
savez on a fait un total gauche quoi le
total gauche en dehors de la période
électorale on a demandé aux Français de
se positionner à gauche à droite au
centre
25% des Français vous rendez compte un
Français sur quatre aujourd'hui se dit
de gauche c'est un niveau historique de
faiblesse jamais la gauche n'a été aussi
faible et c'est une auto-affiliation là
il s'agit pas de faire voilà c'est des
gens qui disent voilà je me sens plutôt
de gauche donc à partir de ça la gauche
a choisi en plus de ça de partir dans un
ordre dispersé et même celle qui
voudraient apporter l'Union participe à
la désunion madame Taubira en effet au
fond l'impression qu'elle rajoute de la
confusion à une gauche qui est déjà
extrêmement confuse très peu lisible de
l'extérieur les Français n'arrivent pas
à mettre derrière aucun candidat de
gauche une ou deux idées précises pour
l'instant ce qui fait qu'aucun candidat
de gauche ne peut dépasser les 10%. si
vous ne dépassez pas les 10%, vous ne
pouvez pas le ticket d'entrée au second
tour même va passer au niveau de 9 à
10%. donc vous ne pouvez pas prétendre
redevenir une force de gouvernement et
donc on a l'impression que la gauche va
être obligée pas simplement peut-être
madame anidalgo mais de passer son tour
et d'envisager enfin de travailler
sérieusement à qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une gauche au 21e siècle
je vais vous donner à la parole de elle
ma mère mais il y a une étude
intéressante que que Viavoice Stewart
show publié pour Libération sur la
gauche c'est un baromètre politique
centré vraiment sur sur la gauche
en ressort de ce baromètre peut-être
déjà l'idée de valeur commune est-ce que
ça existe encore ça
en effet je m'inscris totalement dans ce
qui a été dit précédemment sur cette
radio scopie des électeurs de gauche
donc ceux qui ont voté entre 2012 et
2017 à au moins une de ses élections
pour au moins une liste de la gauche il
y a une lucidité sur le corps électoral
d'une division de la gauche 52% des
électeurs de gauche estiment que ceux
qui réunit aujourd'hui ces électeurs et
plus ce qui divise pardon ces électeurs
est plus important que ce qui les réunit
49% seulement des électeurs de gauche
estiment qu'il existe encore des valeurs
communes donc il y a ce que nous on a
appelé peut-être un peu tribialement des
centres de gravité idéologique qui sont
aussi assez distinctes entre des
électeurs potentiels d'Anne Hidalgo de
Yannick Jadot de Cristiano Taubira aussi
ou encore et encore de Emmanuel Macron
parce qu'il faut pas oublier aussi que
la gauche allait confrontée
une problématique et cette tentation de
d'infidélité je dirais puisque sur ce
corps é que nous avions
identifié 34% estimés pouvoir voter en
2022 pour Emmanuel Macron pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée 23% seulement
s'exprimer en faveur dan Hidalgo 39%
pour Christiane Taubira donc on voit
bien quand même que cette Golf elle est
confrontée aussi à cette mobilité
électorale qui est assez en défaveur en
tout cas pour les candidats qui sont qui
sont en présent c'est je terminerai
peut-être par un des résultats aussi qui
m'a le plus surpris c'est que sur
l'effet déceptif d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
à dire les électeurs de gauche qui
auraient voté en 2017 pour Emmanuel
Macron on se rend compte que si on fait
le bilan des présidents comparés les
électeurs de gauche pensent que Emmanuel
Macron a un aussi bon bilan que François
Hollande donc vous voyez il y a quand
même là aussi un facteur pour le coup du
président de la République sortant qui
va peser encore une fois sur ce corps
électoral de gauche il y aurait presque
à une sorte de vote utile finalement de
certains électeurs de gauche pour
Emmanuel Macron en fait c'est bien sûr
l'incarnation qui est en jeu là et ce
qui est sur la table est-ce que Anne
Hidalgo pose un problème est-ce que la
personnalité dan Hidalgo pose un
problème puisque quand même et au Parti
socialiste il est un programme qui est
mis en place ce n'est pas Anne Hidalgo
qui arrive avec ses petites mesures dans
son sac non il y a quand même de la
concertation on réfléchit au programme
or un Hidalgo ça ne passe pas on voit
bien que cette barre des 5% parfois elle
a la dépasse mais enfin souvent en
dessous donc il y a bien un souci ça
pose la question de la désignation du
candidat dans un camp c'est-à-dire que
on a vu que la primaire c'était pas
forcément avec par exemple exemple de
Benoît Hamon qui a été censé représenter
ce camp là à la dernière présidentielle
et qui s'est voilà vraiment un qui a
échoué
j'allais dire lamentablement moi on en a
pas besoin et donc c'est vrai que on a
eu peur de cette primaire et on s'est
dit tiens Anne Hidalgo et mais qui s'est
dit ça je n'en sais rien candidate
naturel mais pourquoi avec quel il faut
expliquer aussi aux électeurs pourquoi
on choisit un Hidalgo peut-être qu'elle
a toute la résistance d'être la
candidate
est-ce que elle a été vraiment
dalgo se déclare comme la candidate
naturelle du Parti socialiste il faut se
souvenir qu'Olivier fort qui est le
secrétaire national du parti socialistes
plaidait fortement pour que le PS
constitue une alliance avec les
écologistes en acceptant que ce soit les
écologistes qui conduisent
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé
la raison pour laquelle ça ne fonctionne
pas et puis si on revient sur ce que
disait Pascal Perrineau et Monsieur chou
la réalité c'est que en 2017 la gauche
et les écologistes ont été incapables de
réfléchir à aux raisons qui les ont
conduit à cet échec qui était notamment
liée au Landis mais au Vinci mais une
certaine manière qui ont complètement
dévié et détournés et les objectifs de
gauche souvenez-vous de ce meeting de
François Hollande mon ennemi c'est la
finance souvenons-nous de la déchéance
des nationalités souvenons-nous de la
loi travail souvent nous de l'état
d'exception après le terrorisme où nous
avons été que si députés si députés à
nous opposé à la prolongation de cet
état d'urgence qui est passé dans le
droit commun en 2017 avec la loi sur la
sécurité intérieure et la lutte contre
le terrorisme avec avec Monsieur Macron
nous avions dit qu'en effet nous allions
nous habituer comme si nous étions
mithridatisés à des restrictions de
liberté tout ça en effet ne fait que
contribuer à une disons à ce que les
électeurs de gauche soient paumés alors
c'est vrai que ça s'apparait
invraisemblable que face à un président
qui n'est qui est une forme d'imposture
politique par rapport à ce qui nous
avait raconté c'est-à-dire qui est un
président de centre droit qui
responsabilité des forces de gauche et
de l'écologie de ne pas avoir été
capable de construire en 5 ans une
proposition alternative alors le le
retour de la gauche pluriel est-il
encore possible il y en a qui milite
toujours pour et et avec beaucoup de
d'envie et de conviction par exemple
l'euro député Pierre là où tu roux qui
fait une grève de la fin avec une
dizaine de militants il réclament une
union de la gauche à la présidentielle
pour faire face à l'urgence climatique
en écoute tout de suite pierre là où tu
es où
on fait grave de la fin parce qu'on ne
peut pas perdre encore 5 ans dans la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
Emmanuel Macron pendant 5 ans n'a
quasiment rien fait des mesures
homéopathiques et si on a encore Macron
pendant 5 ans ou si on a Valérie
Pécresse qui ne parle jamais du climat
et maintenant 20 ans on a des centaines
de milliers de morts en plus les seuls
qui ont compris l'urgence climatique et
qui apporte des solutions à la hauteur
ce et celle qui se disent de la gauche
et de l'écologie mais s'ils sont divisés
ils n'ont aucune chance aucune d'arrivée
au deuxième tour par contre si on est
rassemblé on peut gagner
Noël ma mère je vais vous redonner la
parole puis après
absolument pas d'accord avec le fait
d'organiser une grève de la fin il y a
des hommes et des femmes qui dans ce
monde ont mené des grèves de la femme
pour des situations beaucoup plus
périlleuses que celles que nous vivons
nous sommes dans une démocratie on doit
pouvoir débattre et je pense que c'est
une manière de de dévaloriser une action
que l'on mène quand il n'y a plus rien
d'autre de possible mais sinon ce qu'il
dit sur le réchauffement climatique
le climat est bien sûr un des sujets les
plus importants mais il faut dépasser le
sujet le plus important
le climat il y a le climat il y a la
biodiversité il y a les effets du
réchauffement climatique sur les
migrants il y a aujourd'hui trois fois
plus de migrants liés au réchauffement
climatique que liés aux guerres et à des
événements extraordinaires et puis il y
a des conséquences sur les inégalités
qui est le plus frappé par le
réchauffement climatique et par ses ce
sont les plus vulnérables c'est-à-dire
ceux qui polluent le moins qui est
aujourd'hui le plus victime de la
pollution de l'air 50000 morts
prématurés par an dans notre pays ce
sont ceux qui habitent le plus près des
périph et le plus près en plus près de
transport la réalité c'est que
l'écologie ne peut être résumé au climat
Bérengère bonté est-ce que vous y voyez
on va terminer là-dessus sur ce chapitre
consacré à la gauche le signe d'une
droiteisation du pays on le dit souvent
elle a dit plusieurs fois sur ce sur ce
plateau ou finalement c'est pas d'abord
la responsabilité je reprends ce qu'ils
annuel ma mère tout à l'heure des
leaders c'est à dire des égaux pour
souffler et des leaders hommes et femmes
confondues qui arrivent pas s'entendre
mais le la responsabilité des leaders
entraîne aussi cette droitisation du
pays enfin c'est l'offre à gauche est
tellement tellement illisible dans son
ensemble et au PS en particulier c'est
juste ça que je voulais ajouter tout à
l'heure en Laetitia parler de du sujet
incarnation peut-être mais qu'a fait le
PS depuis 5 ans enfin c'est le principal
partie de gouvernement à gauche et quand
vous regardez on passait un peu vite sur
les mesures annoncées aujourd'hui enfin
les propositions de Anne Hidalgo mais
pour retenez quoi oui alors il y a le
vote à 16 ans ok
elle va elle va elle va détricoter
la réforme chômage elle va détricoter où
elle va maintenir en tout cas la 62 ans
elle va rétablir la pénibilité enfin
elles sont où les idées en fait qu'a
fait la gauche et qui a fait le PS
depuis 5 ans on va où je trouve c'est un
vrai un vrai sujet et pour répondre plus
complètement à votre question je pense
que
Emmanuel Macron n'est pas qu'un
président de centre droit précisément et
notamment cette crise du covid lui gère
le fait d'avoir le curieux carnet de
chèques facilite quand même les choses
d'une certaine façon et complique les
choses pour la gauche vous avez un
président qui a quand même beaucoup
soutenu
l'activité économique probablement plus
que qu'ailleurs en Europe et ça quelque
part un électeur de gauche
de le critiquer complètement pour ça
pas chaud un mot peut-être quand même
pour boucler ce chapitre gauche de de
Christian tobira comment elle est perçue
dans dans ce baromètre que vous publiez
en libération
écoutez un chiffre 39% des électeurs de
gosses que nous avons interrogé pourrait
potentiellement voter pour Anne Hidalgo
en 2022 c'est le score le plus élevé des
candidatures que nous avons testé mais
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée mais
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est à 38% voilà
Emmanuel Macron à 34% donc finalement le
fait que cette candidature
c'est de créer donc d'accord on est bien
d'accord merci elle te verra est à 39%
Jean-Luc Mélenchon à 38 Emmanuel Macron
a 34 et Anne Gallo à 23 donc vous voyez
cette candidature qui semblerait être la
candidature de l'union de la gauche
naturelle elle ne semble pas en tout cas
aujourd'hui porter par une majorité des
électeurs de gauche donc oui elle est
populaire auprès de l'ensemble des
sympathisants ce qui lui ce qui est
différent ce qui ce qui est différent
pour Anne Hidalgo qui est beaucoup plus
populaire sur son socle général y
compris pour Yannick Jadot donc elle
arrive elle à être populaire auprès de
l'ensemble du corps électoral de gauche
pour autant on l'a vu elle ne performe
pas au surperforme pas dans cette
électorat alors à part maintenant d'Eric
Zemmour avec Zemmour qui cherche son
second souffle je vous propose l'une de
ces interventions c'était hier sur BFM
TV il s'attaque à Marine Le Pen on
écoutait Éric Zemmour Marine Le Pen
m'intéresse pas beaucoup vous savez
c'est une candidature de routine elle
était là la dernière fois elle était là
l'avant-dernière fois elle sera à la
prochaine fois moi vous savez j'ai une
pensée émue pour les électeurs du
rassemblement national est-ce qu'ils
sont prêts à perdre avec Marine Le Pen
en 2032 c'est ça la question qu'il
faudrait se poser c'est un peu notre
Arlette Laguiller de la droite nationale
Marine Le Pen
il y a toujours le sens de la formule
Eric Zemmour Laetitia est-ce qu'il est
dans une sorte d'impasse stratégique
soit il continue de de choquer et il
accroît son rejet on l'a souvent parlé
ici dans une partie de l'opinion là le
taux de détestation d'Éric Zemmour et
très élevé soit il se calme il fait plus
un événement il attire moins les médias
moi je pense qu'il est il n'a jamais été
dans une impasse si je crois qu'on sera
sûr quand on se dit ça et il me semble
qu'il a au contraire un boulevard
c'est-à-dire que pourquoi parce que
justement il est nouveau sur le Chica
politique oui on le connaît parce qu'il
était journaliste mais là il se présente
c'est la seule innovation si vous voulez
en terme d'incarnation dans cette
présidentielle et il peut charrier la
promesse justement d'une révolution ce
que Emmanuel Macron nous avait promis en
2017 vraiment et donc il veut faire
l'union des droites je crois que sur le
papier il a encore devant lui vraiment
une marge de progression au contraire
très forte voilà vraiment j'en suis
convaincu bien que le socle de marine à
peine si vraiment après on s'attache à
des analyse purement politique soit
ultra solide on sait très bien que 90%
des électeurs du RN vont voter RN par
tradition par fidélité mais n'empêche
qu'on n'a jamais connu ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que cette
campagne est totalement imprévisible
c'est à dire qu'on n'a jamais connu le
surgissement d'un candidat comme Éric
Zemmour
à un moment où le pays peut
potentiellement pour plein de raisons et
vous avez les avez évoqué vous aussi
dans votre livre Noël mammaire pour des
raisons mais vraiment qui sont multiples
peu basculer dans un vote effectivement
qui serait révolutionnaire comment vous
jugez sa campagne depuis sa candidature
ça déclaration officielle ce clip qui a
été crié quand vous juger sa campagne
Éric Zemmour écoutez je rejoins ce que
vient de dire Laetitia à savoir que il
occupe un terrain qui était laissé en
jachère avec une Marine Le Pen qui est
plutôt fatiguée si je en effet à sa
troisième candidature et il a profité
finalement d'un terreau qui était
préparé parce que si on regarde c'est ce
que nous avons fait dans notre bouquin
si l'on regarde le contexte
international le fond de l'air est quand
même très brun il s'agisse du trumpisme
et du suprématisme blanc qui s'agisse du
Brésil qui s'agisse des ce que l'on
appelle des démocraties libérales de
Orban ou de la Pologne si on regarde si
l'on descend un petit peu dans
l'entonnoir qu'on regarde le le la
France la France c'est une droite qui a
abandonné ses règles républicaines pour
aller braconner sur les terres de
l'extrême droite y compris d'ailleurs en
utilisant des mots qui sont exactement
les mêmes que ceux de l'extrême droite
une gauche dont on a dit les
renoncements les complaisances une forme
de soumission à un éleo néolibéralisme
dans le ruissellement nourrisselle que
sur les plus riches et puis un contexte
mondial qui est celui d'une
mondialisation qui précarise et cette
précarité cette vulnérabilité elle n'est
pas simplement liée à des conditions
économiques est arrivé cette pandémie
qu'il faut qualifier de fait social
total qui nous concerne tous et qui nous
ébranle à la fois dans nos certitudes
sur notre capacité à maîtriser à
maîtriser le monde et puis et puis c'est
bouleversements climatique qui se
rapprochent chaque année j'allais dire
chaque jour un petit peu plus avec des
parents qui ne savent pas si leurs
enfants vivront mieux que et qui pensent
qu'ils vivront plus mal et donc cette
vulnérabilité c'est lourd il en profite
et donc il peut amener le vote
contestation on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer Thomas on ne sait pas jusque même
les 15 jours avant le premier tour vous
ne savez pas ce qui peut se passer
simplement j'ajouterai une chose que
nous avons que nous avons essayé de
décrire c'est que il faut il faut se
méfier Zemmour ils n'avance pas tout
seul laetitia a écrit un livre sur les
clowns c'est pas un clown c'est
quelqu'un qui a derrière lui
garder les meetings dans lesquels il se
trouve qui est derrière lui des jeunes
de la bourgeoisie dorée et puis il a
derrière lui aussi un capitalisme celui
de Bolloré et de quelques autres qui qui
sont très qui ont beaucoup d'intérêt à
ce qu'ils prospèrent
l'analyse de la de la campagne de
Zemmour et c'est on pourrait presque
faire le même raisonnement pour d'autres
candidats mais est-ce qu'il a grand
chose à dire sur le covid lui par
exemple est-ce que finalement ce
contexte là depuis depuis un mois écrase
pas complètement sa campagne non il a eu
en effet il a surgi sur une scène
politique parce que justement il était
extérieur au système ce sera avec des
multiples
guillemets
de multiples guillemets et il surgit
parce que il assume totalement un
discours de la nostalgie française et il
y a oui dans de multiples secteurs de
l'électorat un discours de la nostalgie
la France a été une grande puissance
elle n'est plus qu'une puissance moyenne
la France ça briller de tous ces feux
dans le monde aujourd'hui elle brille de
manière plus plus mesurée et donc il a
beaucoup
travaillé cette nostalgie française et
il l'exprime avec le talent de polémiste
qui est le sien c'est pas la première
fois d'ailleurs qu'un polémiste de ce
type surgit sur la scène politique
française dans les années
d'entre-deux-guerres il y en a eu de
nombreux exactement sur le même thème à
une époque où la France s'interrogeait
sur ce qu'elle était et ce qu'elle était
dans le monde et aujourd'hui
ça ne change pas tout ça ne change pas
tout quand vous regardez la manière une
enquête vient de sortir sur la manière
dont les Français construisent leur
choix électoral vous vous apercevez que
très nettement devant le numérique c'est
aujourd'hui encore la télévision qui
reste le média qui pour eux est
essentiel même si il y a en effet entre
la télévision et numérique bien sûr des
échanges qui sont des échanges évidents
mais il ne faut pas tout de même si vous
les certes c'est un élément de nouveauté
porteur d'un discours j'allais dire
ultra traditionnel au fond qu'est-ce qui
se dit dans le discours de Zemmour c'est
une très vieux tempérament politique
français qu'on pourrait appeler celui
d'une droite moracienne d'une droite qui
regarde l'avenir toujours dans le
rétroviseur ces propositions sur l'école
c'est bien c'est pas ce caricatural le
retour de la blouse le ministère de
l'Instruction publique la fin de
l'apprentissage des langues étrangères
en
primaire parce que dans ce paysage d'une
certaine manière Marine Le Pen est
beaucoup plus moderne qu'Eric Zemmour
et d'ailleurs les Français le montrent
aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen et crédité
dans le dernier sondage de l'institut
Elbe de 17 % d'intention de vote Éric
Zemmour de 12,5% mais si on regarde les
dynamiques c'est ce que j'essaye de
faire quand on quand on fait en a fait
de 150 100 jours c'est elle est plutôt
stable mais elle est stable avec un
socle solide pour marcher vraiment
solide il est quand même très très
inquiétant c'est que deux candidats
d'extrême droite aujourd'hui en France
font près de 40% à tous les deux et
peut-être que ce qu'il faut dire
prolongement dans le prolongement de ce
que vient d'expliquer Pascal qui est
Perrineau parce que je pense que c'est
très important c'est la question de
l'hégémonie culturelle alors je vais
faire le pédant avec le Paris grammcin
il ne date pas d'aujourd'hui on est
l'héritier Zemmour l'incarnation ça a
commencé quand ça a commencé en 1968
avec Monsieur Alain de Benoît qui est
d'ailleurs toujours proche de Zemmour et
le Grèce le groupe de recherche d'études
sur la civilisation européenne puis deux
ans plus tard blow et Jean-Yves Le
Gallou qui sont toujours prêts de
Zemmour qui créent le Club de l'Horloge
et même la droite qui avait créé le club
80 9 qui dans ces années-là avait
proposé les premiers la préférence
nationale donc cette hégémonie
culturelle on le voit bien avec
l'extrême la droiteisation extrême du
débat public elle est elle est elle est
à l'oeuvre alors est-ce que ce
paris-grâme chien de l'hégémonie
culturel avant la victoire politique
aura lieu bah c'est à la France c'est à
nous les forces politiques de démontrer
que ce n'est pas possible rester très
prudent
le confirmer il y a steward très
rapidement il y a beaucoup de Français
qui ont pas du tout choisi qui soit ne
sont pas sûr de leur choix soit on peut
choisir leur candidat on est d'accord
oui on est à peu près à 40% du corps
électoral qui n'est pas encore sûr de
leur choix et d'ailleurs sur Éric
Zemmour ce qui est très intéressant
c'est cette mobilité électorale selon
les dernières analyses sur 100 électeur
d'Éric Zemmour entre octobre et décembre
2021 36% ont changé d'avis au profit
soit de Valérie Pécresse soit de Marine
Le Pen donc ça montre bien que les
choses ne sont pas encore cristallisées
je me permets juste de rajouter deux
points sur Éric Zemmour le premier c'est
que il patient aussi d'un duel qu'il
perd encore dans l'opinion face à Marine
Le Pen notamment sur des sujets de
prédilection sur la sécurité sur la
l'immigration la présidente du
rassemblement national constitue une
candidature beaucoup plus crédible
auprès de l'opinion et d'ailleurs on ne
l'opinion publique ne pense pas qu'Eric
Zemmour est plus compétent que Marine Le
Pen que c'est un peu un élément de
langage chez lui et je dirais que le
troisième élément qui est très compliqué
aujourd'hui pour exhibour dans cette
nouvelle temporalité de la campagne très
programmatique pour le coup c'est que il
doit passer d'une sphère d'acceptabilité
c'est-à-dire cette proportion de
Français qui estime à peu près un tiers
qu'effectivement il est utile au débat
démocratique qui partage un certain
nombre de constats à une sphère
d'acceptation d'adhésion et ça c'est
vrai que c'est plus compliqué dans une
campagne électorale Bérengère bond quel
que soit le même si Eric Zemmour se
qualifie pas pour le second tour
personne peut le dire autour de cette
table aujourd'hui on en est pas sûr
c'est encore une possibilité de toute
façon est-ce que vous diriez qu'il s'est
installé pour longtemps dans le paysage
politique français
il a il a dit récemment qu'il avait
l'intention de réfléchisser en tout cas
sérieusement à une candidature au
législative il a lui manifestement
l'intention de ne pas faire c'est pas un
aller-retour vers son métier d'origine
on verra bien mais ce qui est sûr c'est
quand
sur le sur la période là qui est dans
laquelle nous sommes que ce que Marine
Le Pen ou lui soit au second tour moi je
suis convaincu qu'il y a vraiment un
Jerry il a évidemment pris
mathématiquement parlant des des voix
ORL mais
l'ensemble du du réservoir et quand même
et plus important le fait que Marine Le
Pen devait être à 25 26% en septembre
elle est descendue de 10 points mais lui
est au sud moi je pense qu'il je crois
qu'il pense à l'après 2022 parce que son
pari ça a été dit c'est l'union des
droites donc c'est un peu de Buisson de
de Villiers et de ceux qui sont assez
complet et on vient de voir que
Guillaume Pelletier est parti de LR pour
aller au front national Madame Le Pen ne
sera sans doute pas candidate une
quatrième fois qui aura-t-il à ses côtés
des wauquiers des marions maréchal et à
ce moment-là effectivement un certain
nombre de digues peuvent tomber nous
amener
prudent parce que on vit beaucoup avec
des schémas d'union on parle de la
droite de la gauche ça ne veut pas dire
grand chose il y a des droites René
Raymond l'avait montré il y a de très
nombreux voilà et il y a des gauches et
quand vous regardez l'histoire de la
gauche on en parlait tout à l'heure les
moments de désunions sont beaux plus
importants que les moments d'union la
gauche dans son histoire depuis le début
du 20e siècle a été beaucoup plus désuni
cuni donc on court après l'union mais
l'union c'est parce que et l'Union des
droites mais attendez l'Union des
droites elle n'existe pas elle n'existe
pas et jusqu'à maintenant ça fait 30 ans
qu'on en parle il va y avoir une fusion
des droits de la droite extrême à la
droite républicaine elle n'est pas là
elle n'a pas été là sous Chirac elle n'a
pas été là sous Sarkozy et elle n'est
pas là qu'on vous écoutez Valérie
Pécresse donc je crois qu'il y a tout de
même
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui si vous voulez
il faut sortir des schémas de la
bipolarisation la cinquième la
République n'est plus du tout
bipolaire
au moins un petit miracle qui s'est
produit pour la droite républicaine qui
est qui ce congrès des républicains
souvenez vous en septembre on avait un
Xavier Bertrand qui n'en démordait pas
ils sont pas de passer très loin d'une
situation un peu identique peut-être
moins moins dispersé quand même que la
gauche mais quand même pas aussi unis
derrière une candidate alors ça ça vaut
ce que ça vaut et on pourra toujours
questionner bien sûr les principes des
primaires parce que le le volant
d'électeurs d'erikioti se fera t-il ça
pour le coup ça reste une inconnue mais
globalement il s'en sortent plutôt bien
avec une candidate qui a plutôt été
assez largement choisie et c'était Inès
alors justement on va on va parler plus
précisément de vallée épaisses Laetitia
vous allez passer au clips sa
communication sa stratégie de
communication elle doit se différencier
d'Emmanuel Macron ah oui puisque le plus
grand danger à la fois pour Emmanuel
Macron et pour Valérie prigresse c'est
de ne pas réussir à se distinguer et
peut-être de ne pas être au pour
l'instant rien n'est écrit donc il y a
deux jours sur Twitter je suis tombée
sur une petite vidéo qui illustre tout à
fait
l'enjeu pour les deux candidats alors je
précise quand même que c'est une vidéo
qui a été postée par le compte de
soutien de la candidate LR qui l'a
elle-même retweetée regardez on en parle
juste après
[Musique]
sinon je peux vous dire il y a des
violences policières si ça vous fait
plaisir que je le dise je l'ai dit je
récuse totalement ce terme de violence
policière
il faut pas confondre d'abord de choses
qui sont les risques terroristes et la
dangerosité et le phénomène des
migrations si on veut lutter contre le
terrorisme de manière efficace il faut
cesser de nier le lien entre terrorisme
et immigration on va passer les grosses
ficelles le noir et blanc pour dire
Macron c'est fini et puis la couleur
pour Valérie présidente mais vous voyez
bien que ces soutiens se posent la
question de comment les différencier et
donc nous prennent par la main pour dire
regardez ils ne disent quand même pas la
même chose et vous le savez bien Thomas
que quand on est comme ça dans
uniformité apparente dans les
propositions comment on se distingue sur
la scène politique surtout à trois mois
du premier tour je sais pas en choquant
en chocolat
si on ne peut pas dire vraiment mon
programme et l'antithèse de mon
adversaire on se met sur le registre de
l'émotion j'aime j'aime pas voilà on va
aimer ou pas Valérie Pécresse et c'est
pour cette raison qu'évidemment elle
choisit des mots qui choque et qu'elle
choisit l'héritage de Nicolas Sarkozy
avec son karcher écouter alors moi je
veux que la peur change de camp je
tracerai les caïdes les voyous les
dealers les mafieux les prêcheurs de
haine c'est eux que je veux harceler et
priver de leurs droits civiques alors
oui je passerai le karcher ça fait 10
ans que François Hollande et Emmanuel
Macron l'oranger à la cave il est temps
de nettoyer les zones de non-droit
ce problème ouais le problème c'est
qu'elle reprend exactement les mêmes
termes nettoyés et karcher que Nicolas
Sarkozy donc bien sûr qu'elle assume
l'héritage de Nicolas Sarkozy qu'elle
envoie un message fort à Emmanuel Macron
sur qui est censé être son talon
d'Achille d'accord simplement la Valérie
Pécresse fait une démonstration de force
de fermeté de dureté est-ce que
manuellement Macron vis-à-vis d'elle et
six mots que cela c'est aux électeurs
effrayants ces gens-là parlent de
violence mais il y a pas c'est eux qui
donnent le ton de la violence cette
violence verbale nettoyée qui fait
référence à des choses qui ont marqué
des crimes contre l'humanité des crimes
de génocide je trouve que c'est
absolument effrayant mais madame
Pécresse peut continuer comme ça comme
le disait Le Pen les électeurs ils
préfèreront leur original à la copie et
en l'occurrence aujourd'hui l'original
c'est celui qui est dans l'excès c'est
celui qui incarne les vieilles idées de
l'extrême droite ses émours et c'est pas
Pécresse Pascal Perrineau comment vous
analysez la dynamique de campagne de
Valérie Pécresse depuis qu'elle a été
désignée par la primaire
il y a eu un effet de surprise dans un
premier temps en effet que attendu quand
on sort avec une marge en plus de ça
aussi importante que celle qui a été la
sienne d'une primaire et que l'on gagne
une primaire en effet on gagne 2 à 3
points et puis ensuite elle est
redescendue à un niveau qui est
intéressant pour elle parce que pour
l'instant elle est parmi celle qui
peuvent s'inviter au second tour et
c'est là si vous voulez une élection
présidentielle c'est une élection a deux
tours je vais pas vous le lapendre il y
a pas simplement un premier tour il y a
un second tour et là autant dans le
premier tour pour l'instant elle a du
mal à aller au-delà de la du petit
sursaut qu'a connu le candidat
LR à la suite des primaires autant en
termes de second tour elle a des
intentions de vote qui sont prometteuses
puisque encore il y a deux jours le
sondage que je citais tout à l'heure est
là-bas montre que Emmanuel Macron contre
Valérie Pécresse 50 50 alors que les
candidats venant de la droite extrême
sont battus avec des scores extrêmement
45% pour Marine Le Pen environ
39-40 pour Éric Zemmour cela montre si
vous voulez la droiteisation du pays
mais attention une élection
présidentielle c'est une élection qui
délivre du pouvoir et là à partir du
moment où ces chiffres vont se répéter
s'il se répète elle pourra apparaître
comme une candidate qui est porteuse de
l'alternative parce que pour l'instant
les Français se disent mais il n'y a pas
d'alternative au fond les sondages
montent qu'Emmanuel Macron est largement
en tête au premier tour et d'autre part
les indicateurs socio-économiques ce que
les politologues Américains appellent le
vote du porte-monnaie sont extrêmement
favorables pour le président sortant
regarde le en particulier la hausse du
pouvoir d'achat même si le français ne
s'en rendent pas beaucoup compte la
baisse du chemin avec les prix de
l'énergie en ce moment voilà là des
indicateurs qui sont des indicateurs
objectivement bon pour un candidat
sortant quelle que soit sa couleur
politique mais à partir du moment où une
alternative peut apparaître la
perception des Français peut changer
surtout quelle ère n'est pas dans l'état
du Parti socialiste vous voyez le Parti
socialiste est un grand parti de
gouvernement une grande force de
gouvernement qui est en train de se
marginaliser ce qui n'est pas le cas de
l'élève c'est fait siphonner par
Emmanuel Macron enfin excusez-moi
est la première force dans les régions
dans les départements dans les grandes
municipalités et de loin donc elle a les
élections locales
le PS d'ailleurs il a encore des fiefs à
résister la mort lente et donc on verra
dans cette élection moi au fond le grand
défi c'est est-ce que l'on va vers une
resusée 2017 c'est-à-dire un clivage
gauche droite qui n'existe plus et au
fond un homme qui se présente comme le
candidat de la société ouverte contre la
société du recentrage national madame
Marine Le Pen où est-ce que le clivage
gauche-droite va réussir au travers de
Vannes Pécresse à se réinviter et là ça
changera tout elle est un mot de
conclusion Bérengère bon sur le l'effet
de la crise sanitaire quand même on en a
un peu parlé parce que moi je veux quand
même que dans cette émission on donne
des clés à noter les spectateurs en
parlant des programmes en parlant du
contenu en parlant de politique et pas
seulement de santé mais bon c'est quand
même ce qui écrase un peu toute
l'actualité de plusieurs jours et donc
et donc ça a anesthésie un peu la
campagne est-ce que ça profite au
président sortant je pense que tant que
cette crise est en cours c'est
clairement lui qui a la main et on le
voit le la gauche a beaucoup de
difficultés à mettre dans le débat
public d'autres sujets et on parlait
d'Éric Zemmour tout à l'heure c'est un
peu la même chose en dehors de grande
émission de télé c'est c'est compliqué
pour lui on est dans cette crise
sanitaire alors tant que ça se passe
entre guillemets bien pour pour Emmanuel
Macron je pense qu'il aura pas beaucoup
de difficultés si ça continue à évoluer
comme comme on le voit là on parle déjà
en février de desserrer les taux vous
imaginez le bénéfice pour un président
de la République qui rend à tout le
monde s'en oxygène un président candidat
bien entendu donc évidemment la petite
séquence là actuelle ce qui se passe
avec avec Jean-Michel Blanquer avec le
petit raté le gros raté même de la
rentrée scolaire peu compliqué les
choses mais je suis pas sûr que ça
change fondamentalement la donne pour
l'instant je crois que ça profite
clairement au président
un peu comme pour avoir travaillé
beaucoup sur Edouard Philippe pour mon
livre il a beaucoup profité en termes de
popularité en termes de crédibilité de
cette crise sanitaire qui n'a peut-être
pas été géré parfaitement mais qui là
qui l'a géré et qui enfin on voit
clairement dans toutes les études que
c'est le moment qu'il lui a profité si
paradoxalement si ça s'améliore on va
dire au mois de février ça donne du
calendrier face au président de la
République mais comme l'a dit Pascal
Perino si la gauche est capable avec les
écologistes de revenir sur des sujets
qui sont prioritaires pour les Français
les sujets prioritaires pour les
Français c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est
l'éducation c'est la santé et qu'ils
sont capables de réhabiliter le clivage
droit de gauche à ce moment-là le
président de la République risque
d'avoir quelques difficultés mais pour
l'instant on ne marche pas par exemple
ils le font aujourd'hui avec la grève
des enseignants et de tous ceux qui les
accompagnent dans l'éducation mais
est-ce que c'est un premier pas vers non
pas une union mais vers une capacité de
remettre les les sujets sociaux les
sujets économiques et les sujets de vie
quotidienne dans le débat je n'en suis
pas sûr merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat Noël ma
mère je rappelle le titre de votre livre
le cas Zemmour comment en est-on arrivé
là c'est publié aux éditions les petits
matins et puis Bérengère donc le Sioux
c'est un portrait devoir Philippe qui
est publié aux éditions de
l'archipel merci encore à